Just before you started with this one,
I do want to say that there's going
to be some French pronunciations,
not a French speaker.
I am doing my best though.
George Washington Simon Boulevard even
punch through via the names of the Great
North and South American revolutionaries.
Remain globally famous
centuries on this one.
Great new wells,
redell many of forgotten he was a nobody.
He became a somebody only
after 50 years of obscurity,
a freed slave who wound up leading the
only successful large scale slave revolt
in history.
The general who made Haiti the second
free colony in the whole of the Americas.
His name was too,
so the river tour,
Aka the Black Napoleon born into
slavery over to his early life,
was an inspiring tale of overcoming
a racist system to live a free man,
but it was his later years that were truly
remarkable as he kept on rising until
he became ruler of the society that had
enslaved them and enlightened thinker,
a prescient philosopher and a
brilliant general that over to you.
I was also a man who dared to dream
of freedom even if he wouldn't live.
To see those dreams fulfilled,
this is the story of the greatest
black revolutionary who ever lived
imagined.
History is a vast cave,
swelling with shadows,
and each person's life is a distant torch.
Some of those lives like Napoleon's,
a gigantic pyres burning so brightly
that you can't possibly miss them,
but others,
most of them a little
more than matchsticks,
almost invisible.
It's into this category,
the early life of two song
that ever true or false,
remarkably for a man who would go
on to liberate an entire nation,
we know almost nothing about him.
We can say for certain that he was
born in the French colony of Sandman,
now known as Haiti and
1741 just slave parents.
We can also say that his original name
was to som Breda off to his plantation,
but beyond that,
everything is a myth and shadow the life
of a slave and sandy was not pretty.
Ninety percent of the population lived
in shackles while a few tens of thousands
of whites and fried collards,
as they were known existed
in a state of luxury.
The average slave life
expectancy was only 21 years.
Those who downs tools
fought back or ran away,
could expect to be blinded or
mutilators yes to Seoul was lucky.
One of the consistent themes of the
conflicting accounts of his early years is
that he was born onto the plantation
of a relatively enlightened master.
The wound you saw taught him French,
allowed him to gain some medical knowledge
and promoted him to a job as a horse
trainer in 1776.
He even granted to song is freedom.
It's at this point to solemn
briefly resends to the historical.
He married and had two
kids and it's remarkably.
He even though disliked the own after
this 15 more years passed in which to saw
left,
not even the slightest footprint on
history by the time 1791 rolled around,
he was 50 and age at which most normal
biographies are starting to wind down by
50.
Napoleon had already
conquered half of Europe,
been defeated at Waterloo,
and then send him to exile by comparison
to Sony was a small time farmer,
may ember in that dark cave
of history that's on a diesel,
had every reason to believe he was
going to die and nothing but obscurity.
Thankfully for our story though,
winds of change were starting to blow
in Europe in no time at all to song and
everyone in Santa Monica would be
consumed by the oncoming hurricane.
In 1799,
a group of friends,
radicals unknowingly lit the fuse on
a gigantic pile of dynamite marked the
French revolution.
The ensuing explosion would
shake up human history.
In most cases,
the effects will be felt until
a few years down the line,
but Sandman wasn't most cases.
It was a radical tinderbox barely kept
in check by far away Paris almost as soon
as the French Revolution spock's the
entire country went up in flames.
By mid 17,
91,
everyone was aware of the storming of
the Bastille and the declaration of the
rights of man.
This was a problem because the declaration
was pretty clear that the rights of
men,
what universal,
which in Santa Mom,
they pretty clearly we're not
the wide stumped on the colors.
He dumped on the freed blacks.
He dumped on the slaves
with the whole system,
designed as a pyramids of exploitation.
If everyone was suddenly equal,
sound among would cease
to exist for whites.
The French revolution represented both
a threat and the chance to speak less
often declare a white supremacist
republic for the college.
It represented a chance to
finally knock the winds down,
a peg or two that year.
The two sides were almost
openly potting revolts.
In doing so,
they failed to realize that a much larger
group had seen in the revolution and
even bigger chance than they did out on
the plantations and in the darkness of
the forests,
black slaves had began whispering
to one another by the summer.
The whispers that turned into an idea,
which in turn became a plan.
Finally,
on the night of August,
the 14th,
17,
91,
a group of slaves met outside the
capital of lcap performed a secret voodoo
ceremony that are under the stars.
They swore by blood to do the unthinkable.
They agreed to results if
the French revolution started
small before snowballing
into an unstoppable avalanche,
the Haitian Revolution went straight to
the annihilating wall of ice and theory.
On August the 25th thousands of white
plantation owners were woken by gangs of
slaves dragging them from their beds,
stabbing them,
shooting them,
beating them to death.
French children were dismembered.
Their heads displayed on poles
outside of their former homes.
Fires were started.
Entire plantations bend to the grounds,
the horizon,
the turns and apocalyptic read.
The bloodshed was nearly worse.
The freed slaves in the countryside
and the house slaves in the towns that
intended to coordinate the uprising,
but the field slaves jumped the gun
and the whites and colors were able to
rounds up and massacre the town's slaves,
but it only put off the inevitable.
By late September,
over 100,000 slaves were in revolt
and the cap was flooded with refugees.
Carrying horror stories
of rape and mutilation,
the Haitian revolution it had begun,
so where was to solve in all
of this while he was lying low,
refusing to either join the
uprising or to condemn it,
something he was simply waiting to see
if the revolt was going to burn out.
Others think he was giving his
distance in case of white reprisals.
Whatever the reason is,
September into October,
and the fires grew until the countryside
looked like a vision of hell.
Fifty year olds to song
finally made his choice.
First,
he shipped his wife and
children off to Santa Domingo,
the Spanish colony occupying the other
half of the islands today known as the
Dominican Republic.
Then he quietly smuggled his old wide
master and his family onto a boat headed
for the USA at lost with
no one left to care for.
He freed,
slave,
abandoned his farm and
disappeared into the forest.
It was the start of what would
become a remarkable career,
but not straight away because of
his medical knowledge to songs.
First posting was less black
and Napoleon and more male.
Florence Nightingale,
a doctor for Georgia Bay ourselves.
Slave Amit,
he kept out of the thick of the fighting
as 70 91 raged on and the bodies began
to pile high by the year's end,
some 4,000 whites and
15,000 blacks with debt.
The economy was in ruins.
The plantations were husks,
and a third of Omar was in the hands of
the rebellious slaves by the time 1792.
Dawn's though to song was finally
beginning to show his promised given 600
minutes of commands,
he quickly proved such an effective
fighter that is ranks ballooned to 4,000,
although we're still answering to buy
or sell now effectively had his own army
among their number was Jacques,
Jack Dslr,
a runaway slave who would become
two songs and right on men.
While two songs on the gained fame for
showing clemency to any whites they
captured.
That's the law when in the
exact opposite direction,
a sadist with an overwhelming
hatred of whites.
This alone which inflict old
plantation punishments on his captives,
gouging out eyes,
and mutilating any French
that he encountered before
displaying their body parts
on Pike's.
Yes,
it'd be wrong to call Dessa law,
merely a psychopath.
Everything he did to his white captives
had seen done by whites to slaves
countless times before.
White blonde had buried slaves alive,
bore them to death,
made them eat their own excrement.
It said that the sleep of
reason produces monsters.
Well,
that's a long,
was the perfect monster for a system that
has long ago lost all sense of reason
with decimals.
How do song was able to capture a huge
swath of the countries north as 17.
Ninety three began their
partnership at turned to songs,
fighters since perhaps the most
effective slave army in Santa Monica.
It was at this time that he changed
his name to look over it too,
which can be read as opening the way
a possible reference to his military
victories,
but the war on Santa more had
reached a kind of stalemate.
Whites were holed up in their cities.
The colors were attempting to establish
a separate state in the south.
The other slave army commanders were
just as powerful as to song what the
commands are needed was an outside force
that would come and give the entire war
a gigantic shove.
Luckily that was bound to happen.
Seventy,
93 is the year both Spain and Britain
decided to invade sound them all.
It was the chaos in metropolitan
mainland France that allowed the two
superpowers to act with impunity.
Seventeen 93 was the year of the
reign of terror in the anarchy.
The revolution has unleashed.
No one had any time to care about
what was happening in the colonies.
Sound them all has long been prized by
other Caribbean powers in both London and
Madrid.
I wanted to take it,
but while the British
just straight up invaded,
the Spaniards arrived with a plan.
They're calling this in.
Santa Domingo opens communication channels
with the slave army leaders promising
to respect their freedom.
If they fought for the Spanish crown,
it was a political master stroke.
Most of the slave leaders
signed up to fight for Madrid's,
including the if a tour.
They were tired of France and so nothing
new under a British regime accepts the
change of language.
However,
there were good reasons
for thinking Luva too.
It wasn't exactly down with this pledge
of allegiance to Spain that sorta bounce
of c come some of the remaining
French troops in Santa Mall.
We're in a desperate position,
but that fortunes,
they were about to change.
The chaos in Paris had briefly calmed
down enough for the new revolutionary
government to send out a delegation
led by the portly abolitionist,
leggings for the seat sown,
Phonak's arriving in hazy sulfonex quickly
divine's that there was only one way
to save the colony from
implosion and conquest,
and it just so happened to align perfectly
with his own beliefs on always the 29
slash 17 slash 93.
He did the unthinkable.
He unilaterally freed all the slaves.
At first I didn't believe him,
but 17,
94 lumberton interview.
It became clear that not only did softball
next mean to keep the slaves free,
the governments in Paris
actually backed him.
It was at this point the Louver tour and
made the decision that would catapult
him to greatness over to us.
Army had taken control of the mountains,
giving them a natural,
easily defended base,
so over to your new that he
was in a position of strength
when he announced that
he was defecting from the Spanish.
From now on,
he would be fighting for the French.
The decision changed course of the war.
Labor deals army marched down from the
mountains and decimated the Spanish
forces and their black allies.
Generals who nominally been over to
her superiors only days before found
themselves forced into retreat
into Santa Domingo as an overseer.
Cabs driving forwards.
The Spanish eventually capitulated
having just lost her separate water.
France in Europe.
They agreed to give up Santa Domingo
that vanquished black allies while they
were sent into exile,
but Louver tour.
He wasn't done yet,
but fitting his army around.
He now launched his full force against
the coastal cities occupied by the
British.
Although the British would cling onto
their sound Amar enclaves for a few more
years,
the game,
it was up under new verticals,
onslaught.
They were beaten down until the general
was able to make peace on his own terms,
the deal that Britain could restart
trading with sound Amar on solar condition
that louverture refrained from fermenting,
slave rebellion in Jamaica,
sends it over to your new British trade
would be Kasia rebuilding the wall,
shattered economy.
This was a win win.
You've got everything you wanted,
and the British got to back
out with a shred of dignity,
still intact as the British slowly
packed up and left over to her,
turned his attention to the difficult
problem of peace for the remaining whites
and colors.
This would have been a
time of paralyzing fear.
The slave armies were notorious for
their massacres and life under a former
slave must have been terrifying.
Prospect.
They have not counted on the overdose
greatness rather than reprisals.
Lived here pursued a
policy of reconciliation.
He forgave war crimes committed by whites.
He invited the plantation owners back,
offering them the same plantations that
owns before and the chance to make their
money back.
He instituted a policy of colorblindness.
Everyone would be equal and no
white would persecute any black,
just as no black would take vengeance
upon any white for the slaves.
He maintained their freedom.
They would have to return to the old
plantations and work for two years,
but they would receive wages and corporal
punishments would be banned after the
two years were up.
That'd be free to go wherever they
pleased it's moments such as these,
the show.
Why do you sold over to your
remains a fascinating figure.
There was a man who just spent five years
fighting a brutal race war and now he
was extending the hand of friendship to
the very people who tried to kill him
and all of interest to general.
The video was capable of being
a statesman who's pragmatism,
good Bible Washington's,
but there was still a dark side to leave
it to you and it went by the name of
Joel.
Jack.
This along in the
carnage of the civil war.
The colored said,
succeeded in carving out a small state
in the south under the command of Andre
Rigor in 1799,
low poverty or send us along
down to terminate the outpost,
which decimal did with extreme prejudice.
The war of knives was brutal.
It doesn't all slaughtered anyone who
could even conceivably be a supporter of
rigo leaving a trail of death in his wake.
While Lovato was busy consolidating
power in the north by exiling something
accent of the French authorities.
That's the little town in the
south into central wasteland.
That reconciliation with the
colored became impossible.
Bloody is.
It was the war of knives did succeed
and reunifying Santa Mall for the first
time since 17,
91.
The entire country was under the control
of one man and that man was over to
her.
As the clock ticked over
in the 19th century,
began louvered here was
slowly rebuilding the economy,
reestablishing race relations between
blacks and whites and making plans to
eliminate slavery in Santa Domingo.
In short,
this extraordinary man was
at the peak of his career.
It would take the arrival on the world
stage of a man even more extraordinary
than lower tier to stop him.
Unfortunately for the
population of Santa Monica,
that man was already waiting in the wings,
just as the Black Napoleon
was consolidating,
has control over Sandamala in Europe,
the Real Napoleon was doing
the same thing with France.
Seventeen 99,
so on.
Napoleon Bonaparte go from being a
general in the revolutionary army to first
console of France as it
is with many great men.
One stage simply wasn't big
enough for both of them.
One of them,
Napoleon's first acts was to declare
the French colonies would be governed by
special rules,
meaning the declaration of the rights of
men would not apply since over to your
own,
has not actually declared
independence from France.
Instead of insisting that he
was ruling on behalf of Paris,
this was something of a problem.
Everyone knew that a slave economy
could not be ruled by a former slave.
Not that things went immediately south
though Louver to you publicly praised
Napoleon,
recognizing him as the
new leader of France,
and he swore his loyalty to him.
His actions seem to mollify Napoleon,
the first consult confirms that over too,
as the legitimate leader of
the colony of Santa Monica,
but he also issued him with a warning.
Lova too,
was not under any circumstances
to invade Santa Domingo.
So now can you guess what you're did next?
At the time,
Santa Domingo was a vassal state,
technically ruled by frogs,
but still in the hands of
Spanish administrators.
It also continued to practice slavery,
something lovatare couldn't
tolerate his on his doorstep.
In Eighteen,
oh one he marched in,
sees the country and declared
slavery abolished back in France.
The mouth hits the ventilator incense
to bind it over to his actions.
The government demanded something be done.
Napoleon himself,
he communicated.
He had a vague plans.
Who invade America has
recognized that sound.
Amal slave armies could help
make that dream a reality,
but his wounded ego eventually got
the better of him at the end of 18.
Oh,
one.
The first console dispatched a military
expedition under the control of Charles.
Look to retake sound mall.
Not long after he passed the Lore of May
the 20th bringing slavery back to the
colonies.
It was the beginning of the ends of both
do sauna over tour and French control
of Santa Maher on paper over to you
should have been able to rally popular
support in the face of a French invasion.
Sadly,
in reality is new equal
society was not very popular.
The economy was still a shambles and the
returned whites resented the empowered
blacks.
The colored still remember
decimals atrocities.
The blacks,
well,
they may have technically been free,
but they were still stuck
on that plantations of the
three major demographics
and we'll send them all,
not one felt comfortable
with the inverters.
Phoenix state as look like made landfall.
First,
the whites flocked to his side and the
colored and then many of the slaves.
Finally,
even George drank the salon turns on his
old friends and through his lot in with
the French and this one,
it was the end for lower tier.
After a few months of token resistance
over to your contact at the clerk and
promise today down his arms in exchange
for a guarantee that the French would
not reimpose.
Slavery began like agreed on two songs,
suspended military operations,
retiring to his old farm.
He was surprised with an invitation to
meet a French general at an out of the
way plantation.
It was clearly a trap,
but over to here was maybe just too tired
by his sudden fall from power by that
point,
whatever the reason he accepted
as he arrived at the meeting spot,
he was arrested under the
orders of Napoleon himself
and deported France to solo
over to your manual,
had freed the slaves are ruled sound
all for one brief shining moments would
never see us home again.
Send to the Jura mountains
in southern France.
Liberty.
I spent the next year being beaten,
neglected,
and left to rot.
He wrote a bits like the dreamed a lot,
but in the cold mountain,
air is health collapsed by this point,
a man in his sixties,
lover to as body soon failed him.
He succumbs to repeated infections
before finally slipping away.
On April the seventh,
18,
oh,
three black is white counterpart woods.
In 20 years,
the Black Napoleon died alone,
unloved,
and an exile is achievements
seemingly forgotten.
Before he went over to her,
did have time to write his thoughts
down on Santa Monica Future.
He felt the genie was out of the bottle
and soon another black like in would
come along to permanently free
the slaves and expel the French.
He was more right than he knew.
As he lay dying.
That's along.
I had switched sides again.
The cleric responded by trying to commit
genocide against the slave population.
Even using ship holds filled with
fumes as primitive gas chambers.
This was a bad decision.
The dark force driving decile law
was more than equal to the clerks.
Demons stands in a genocidal war.
They could only be one winner in 18.
Oh,
three decimal systematically exterminated.
All of the whites in more men,
women,
children,
soldiers,
civilians,
each were butchered by a caravan
of death that offered no mercy.
Only polls,
Brits and Americans were spared the former
because many of them had arrived with
the clerical.
You need to switch sides the latter to
you purely because that's a long knew
that he needed British and American
trade to rebuild the economy.
The Clark himself didn't live
to see this final French defeat.
He died of yellow fever in November of 18.
Oh,
two.
Just after launching his campaign
of genocide on January the first 18,
oh,
four dozen law renames the nation Pacey
and declared independence from France.
The slaves had done the impossible that
fought for their freedom and then one,
although Haiti would endure
centuries of economic misery,
natural disasters,
and occupation by powers
including the United States,
it would never again be ruled by France.
All of this happens because
of one man to Solon.
Level two,
you may not have lived to see it,
but his nation could never have one.
It's freedom without him.
It's thanks to the Black Napoleon that
Santa more didn't really become another
British or Spanish outpost,
and it's thanks to his insistence on
ending slavery that Haitians remained free
from 1794 onwards.
It was a great commander,
a shrewd statesman,
and a man who tirelessly
advocated for racial equality.
His dream of creating an equal sound,
Amal may have failed,
but it was a noble dream or
the same for that reason,
if no other to soul
life for cure the slave,
it became a leader
deserves to be remembered.
So I really hope you
found that video interest,
and if you did,
please do give us a like below and
don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday
and hit that bell button because
subscribed doesn't work
like it used to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get all
videos in your notification feed,
you do need to hit that bell.
So do that,
and as always,
I'll see you in the next video.